I'm going to begin the show today with a
topic that's not quite as heavy as some
of the topics we've covered recently but
still one that is is heavy in a in a
different sense of the word without a
lot of fanfare a movement has been
underway in this country for some time
to Outlaw the idea of being fat phobic
which of course literally means fear of
fat people now of course like most of
the other new phobias that have been
discovered in the past 15 minutes or so
fat phobia is a misnomer it doesn't
exist I mean no one's really afraid of
fat people just like no one's afraid of
people who call themselves transgender
people are afraid of being fat however
which makes sense a fear of obesity is
really just a fear of heart disease and
early death which are both things that a
normal person is afraid of or at least
interested in avoiding but this is still
not a fear of of other people who are
fat now it's true that many Americans
have let's say um an aesthetic aversion
to morbid obesity but that's also
understandable for lots of deeply
ingrained biological reasons humans have
come to Value traits like physical
fitness we also tend to prefer that
women look like women and men look like
men because that's how the species
propagates itself this is human nature
the only way to Outlaw it is to Outlaw
humanity and increasingly it looks like
that is indeed the goal earlier this
year in New York City fat activists
successfully campaigned to enact a law
that makes it illegal to discriminate
against people on the basis of their
weight and what this means in practice
is that every employer that fires a fat
person in the city of New York can now
look forward to an investigation from
the city's Commission on human rights
because it might be a human rights
violation to fire someone who happens to
be fat watch another fight for equality
across the board New York City taking
steps to ban discrimination based on
someone's weight or height I would
reporter dollar miles has the story I
prefer fat I think that using that you
know it takes away any of the negative
connotation embracing the word fat
that's what Victoria Abraham does on her
social media accounts using the handle
fat fat feminist the 22-year-old has the
attention of more than
120,000 followers in most places in the
United States you can get fired for
being fat and have no protection at all
which is crazy because this is a fairy
fat country the passage of the bill
Thursday means New York now joins poor
other cities with weight discrimination
laws on the books and Michigan and
Washington State are there gaps in this
bill for sure but I think this is a
perfect first
step so there are still gaps in the bill
remarks the fat activist and if there's
one thing that fat activists want to
ensure it's that there are no gaps
anywhere they want to fill that space
they want to fill every space and
they're going to expand their ranks
until they've accomplished that
objective they certainly don't want
anyone to lose weight they don't want to
reduce the number of people who die due
to obesity in this country which is one
in six by some estimates that would make
too much sense the last thing they want
us to they want is to encourage
Americans to become less obese instead
as you just heard they want to reorder
reorder all of society so that we can
accommodate the morbidly obese and to
that end the New York legislation bans
discrimination on height and weight in
the areas of housing the workplace and
public accommodation now the only real
exception is for jobs where in the eyes
of New York City politicians it is quote
essential for people to be physically
fit now what does that mean exactly and
how often have people actually been
fired for being obese in New York well
those are good starter questions when
you're talking about passing a sweeping
new law like this which has
ramifications for every business in the
city and yet no one has any answer to
either of them what little data we do
have doesn't seem very credible for
example there's one study on fat Folk
phobia that was cited by The Washington
Post recently and using data from
1979 the the paper concludes that quote
a woman's hourly pay can drop by almost
2% for every one unit increase in
BMI you know it's a standard story we've
all heard it a woman gets called into
the boss's office and told that she's
getting a pay cut because she's too fat
happens all the time right except for
the fact that it never happens at all
and if it did by the way like if you're
if your uh pay dropped by that amount
for every one unit increase in B BMI
well lots of people in this country
would be getting paid like negative
$50,000 a year at this point they would
be getting charged money to go to work
if that's actually how it
worked the whole premise is absurd and
yet as the Daily Mail reports this week
these laws against fat phobia are
becoming increasingly common even
Colorado which is the thinnest state in
the entire country the one that is
presumably the least fat phobic is now
about to pass a law outlawing
discrimination on the basis of weight
and that would be the first time a law
like this has been passed Statewide in
decades Michigan apparently passed a law
Banning discrimination based on weight
around 50 years ago followed by
Washington State but now it's becoming
trendy and so Vermont Massachusetts New
Jersey are all looking to do the same
along with a bunch of other cities as
well are looking to pass their own
ordinances but Colorado is unique
because it's a state that even accepting
these fat activist standards um would
seem to need these protections the least
their obesity rate is just 25% which is
sadly quite Low by us standards this
Christmas season don't let the
government be the Grinch of your savings
right now you can diversify your savings
with physical precious metals while
stockpiling free silver in your home
safe don't miss out on Birch gold
group's most popular special of the year
now through December 22nd for every
$5,000 you spend with Birch gold they'll
send you a 1 o Silver Eagle Coin for
free text Walsh to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility now you can purchase gold
gold and silver and have it shipped
directly to your home or have Birch
Gold's precious metal specialist help
you convert an existing Ira of 401k into
a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no money
out of pocket and they'll send you free
silver for every $5,000 you purchase so
keep it for yourself give something with
real value as a stocking stuffer this
year whatever you want to do just text
the keyword Walsh to 9898 98 to claim
your eligibility with A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold text Walsh to
98 98.9
and claim your eligibility for free
silver on qualifying purchases before
December 22nd that's Walsh to 998
9898 since roie way was overturned the
left has lost their mind making abortion
their official Sacrament but the
Grassroots Pro lifee efforts which are
now more important than ever are booming
prif Pro lifers have not gone away in
fact they've increased in number one of
the efforts that I support is 40 Days
for life because they're changing hearts
and Minds in blue pro-abortion states
with 1 million Volunteers in 1,600
cities 40 Days for life holds peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities 40
Days for life has opened a record number
of locations since row was overturned
and they've grown in volunteers the
success has come with new unwanted
attention from the doj 40 days just made
national headlines because they're suing
the doj on behalf of their volunteer
Mark Hal who had his house raided by the
FBI they're going on offense against our
compromis FBI and doj and you can help
them fight their ongoing legal battles
and and uh and pursuit of free speech
for their volunteers including Mark Hal
by giving a tax-deductible gift of any
amount at 40 days forlife.com that's 40
days forlife.com but they're about to
get some new regulations for the benefit
of The Morbid Le obes according to uh
the hill quote the law aims to prevent
landlords from denying rentals based on
weight limits and to imp Implement
workplace accommodations for overweight
Americans now you're supposed to accept
that explanation of the law on face
value but it does raise a couple of
obvious questions first of
all how big do you have to be to exceed
the weight limit for an apartment
building and second what kind of
accommodations are workplace is supposed
to make for the
obese well it's hard to get a straight
answer to either of these questions but
if you look around on social media you
will find some more specific proposals
uh you might have seen this Tik Tok
video that was everywhere a few weeks
ago we played it on the show it features
Jaylen Cheney who's a um self-described
travel and lifestyle Creator based in
Vancouver and here she is to give you
some idea of what these fat activists
want and what kind of accommodations
they're looking for uh let's watch that
again I'm on a mission to revolutionize
the travel industry and make it a more
accessible accepting accommodating place
for all the needs of plus-size Travelers
matter just as much as anybody else and
today I'm going to cover what we are
looking for in accessible size inclusive
Hotel amenities size inclusive Hotel
amenities are crucial for ensuring that
plus-size Travelers feel welcomed
accommodated and comfortable during
their stay we deserve an environment
that respects our needs and body
diversity these are the exact steps that
hotels can take to be more size
inclusive and accessible for Travers of
all sizes number one on the list provide
sturdy wider chairs without armrests in
guest rooms lobbies and common areas to
accommodate different body sizes and
types number two on the list ensure beds
with strong support and a higher weight
capacity along with providing reinforced
chairs and wider bathroom facilities
number three make elevators and hallways
spacious to allow for easy movement of
larger individuals and those utilizing
Mobility devices number four install
grab bars in showers and near toilets
offer ajust ible handheld shower heads
and raise toilet seats for added
accessibility number five train staff to
be respectful understanding and
accommodating to Travelers of all
sizes so Cheney is basically
demanding that every hotel and
restaurant in the United States be
raised to the ground and rebuilt with
new super wide hallways and wide
bathrooms and elevators she also wants
to make sure uh make make life worse for
everyone else including by removing
chairs with armrest in rooms common
areas Etc separately she's also demanded
that Airlines provide extra free seats
to obese people so that they have room
to spread out she said quote as
plus-size Travelers my partner and I
have unfortunately experienced
discrimination and and discomfort while
flying now she doesn't care about the
discomfort that she causes non-obese
passengers on the plane really what
she's saying is that she doesn't want
those people on the plane at all she
wants their seat uh for
free and she's not alone the Dei website
feminity assembled a list of similar
demands on behalf of fat activists and
here are just a few of them quote
communal spaces like dining areas
conference rooms and relaxation rooms
should have furniture like chairs desks
sofas and tables that are inclusive of
fat people it's best to avoid stools
tiny benches or chairs with RI rigid
armrests creating a fat inclusive office
also means rethinking every inch of the
space avoid tight
Corners yes rethink every inch of space
remodel your entire building for the
sake of people who have eaten so much
that they can no longer comfortably walk
down the hallway or sit in a
chair these are the demands and they're
actually being met in London a few years
ago the mayor banned ads featuring
attractive women in swimsuits from
appearing on public transit one of the
ads asked are you Beachbody ready and
that's hate speech in London now
evidently tens of thousands of people
signed a petition to get the ads removed
they even vandalized it with
graffiti and ultimately they got what
they wanted in this country the School
of Public Health at the University of
Illinois Chicago recently proposed that
the word obesity should be banned
entirely as the independent reported the
university claims that weight
discrimination remains quote one of the
only forms of discrimination actively
condoned by
society which is obviously not remotely
true and the university knows it's not
true because they had an affirmative
action plan which discriminates against
whites and Asians in all aspects of
Admissions and
hiring I mean that's one of the most
blatant forms of discrimination
imaginable and also one of the worst
because it's based on something people
can't
control but they condone that they
participated in that they practiced it
that's the thing about alleged
discrimination against the obese now
most of these examples of discrimination
are just made up and ridiculous but even
if there was some discrimination that
was actually going on
you know it it wouldn't be in the same
ballpark as discrimination based on
something like race because obesity no
matter what anybody says is a
choice it is the result of a deliberate
lifestyle obesity is a consequence of
behavior if you are uh
400b and feeling discriminated
against well you put yourself in that
position and the good news is that you
can get yourself out of it a white man
facing affirmative action discrimination
can't do anything to be not
white but an obese person can and should
and and for his own health must do
something to make himself not
obese you know obese people have become
the next big victim group in America but
they are like so many of the new modern
victim groups victims of their own
behavior and that's why this uh is such
a a growing and popular victim group
because you know anyone can eat their
way into it just lie on the couch and
Gorge yourself on Pringles and very soon
you too will be able to recast any
criticism of you as
bigotry you too will be handed a get out
of accountability free
card you too can claim that anyone who
upsets you or disagrees with you or
annoys you is some kind of IST or
phobe and in this way the fat acceptance
movement is no different from any other
faux victimhood movement in the country
but it does stand apart to SU extent as
perhaps the most farsal example of
modern society's kind of Meir
ethos the whole idea behind the movement
is that the world should rearrange
itself for the sake of making room for
the morbidly obese and they mean that
literally we need to literally rearrange
the furniture so that these people can
fit inside the
room so it's really on the nose to the
point of
absurdity and of course the much easier
more cost effective uh fairer more sane
approach is for the morbidly obese to
make some simple lifestyle changes so
that they can more easily include
themselves in these spaces like if you
walk into a space and you say I can't be
included in the space because I
literally can't fit here then there are
things that you can
do and changes you can enact
immediately that will fix that problem
the problem is that that that puts the
onus on the
individual that requires willpower and
sacrifice and that can never be allowed
you know in our age everyone else must
sacrifice so that the individual
sacrifices nothing the self re Reigns
Supreme everyone else must bow to the
self Society must change for the sake of
the
self civilization must re order
itself the world must stop on its AIS
and and spin the opposite direction if
that is what the self
demands the self must be required to do
nothing and the world has to do
everything now the problem of course is
that every individual is part of the
world which is how you end up with these
self-serving laws that hurt the people
they're supposedly trying to help when
you try to have a society where each
individual is a God who wishes and
proclivities and demands Trump the good
of humanity and Society you end up with
a predictable mess you end up with Decay
and collapse and
confusion and we've seen this confusion
for a while now a decade ago New York
banned large sodas in order to make
everybody
skinnier and now they're mandating that
everybody treat obesity as if it's
natural and
healthy but no matter what the one thing
politicians don't want to do because it
would diminish their power is to let
people will make their own
choices and yeah that includes the
freedom to eat and drink to
extraordinary
excess but also more importantly it
includes the freedom to criticize those
who do hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there